foreign
Chad is really deciding my destiny now
oh dear
why did I make this pole most people are
saying yes
uh
uh Paul's not over yet
but I'm in the berserk the first game
it looks like yes is gonna win
thank you
right
yeah yes is going to win okay berserking
time
[Music]
so thank you great content much love
appreciate the love
[Music]
okay focus time
[Music]
oh it's not good
dollar exchange
[Music]
oh
[Music]
my God
foreign
[Music]
let's go
nice okay leech School let's go I'm
staying here for now though
oh what a game
okay
I'll be berserking every in this
tournament
oh dear
oh
okay
I'm still shaking after that last game
man
a little bit
okay this is under control at least
there we go okay
two down
let's go
yeah I left my watch in the other room
what to do don't have my heart rate
monitor okay Eric commonly requesting
some schliemann content okay just for
you oh no semen I'm playing whatever
this is
this is my attempted streaming
oh dear
oh dear
okay Queen D6
I was studying the Rosso Gambit other
day
uh
I think it was yesterday actually
okay this is actually reasonable
ones are hit
mainly F2
or graph two E3
were you expecting to play hyperbolic
due to two poles
wait what
I don't know what that refers to I left
hyper bullet out of the pole that I
didn't think it would be likely
but
oh hyperbolic because I'm berserking
every game yeah pretty much
uh
I wasn't expecting to play hyperboleth
though I was expecting actually ravages
like rapid usually wins over Blitz and
bullets foreign
I could have promoted tonight
okay this is working out
okay
okay keeping up the berserk streak
the every game is hyper bullet basically
for me
no one's berserked back so far
okay just for calling Roddy I'll try and
play streaming every game with black
but there's no guarantees may my
opponent play the scotch last game
oh I just beat syncopeed oh good game
single kid
yeah I could have been in trouble in the
opening that game like Queen H5
uh there's a chance for light
early on
Carol con time
yeah I want to play G5 and open the H
file
or just take advantage of the ping pong
the G6 oh G6 was not a great move
but that's kind of working out
hmm
okay things are getting kind of spicy
here
I should probably Castle soon
oh time is very good for me
okay I was running Maiden one there
okay games go on
that's four in a row
it's gonna be a short tournament
we're already uh about eight minutes in
thank you Matt Turner a new Prime sub
oh Shawarma asking ready for some
blindfold challenges yeah I did
blindfold chess yesterday for the first
time
in a long time
um I'd probably be up for more
oh not a good poo move
it's getting weird though
uh that's not good
oh no my queen
actually
Queen is alive
oh no
this is bad
or is it
still alive
um
oops
foreign
oh that was a dirty time scramble
barely won that
okay
keeping the streak alive
uh we'll go for another semen
okay we're playing the rossogue on it
okay this looks reasonable
this looks very reasonable
uh
I could have taken the queen but
this is slightly better
so I win two minor pieces Queen's still
hit
okay we'll trade
oops
I was expecting King H2 for some reason
I don't know why though
oh no
this is not good
no I should have played the other Pawn
yes
let's go Whitehead Maiden one
wow
wow okay I won that not the cleanest win
I mean I was up so many pieces and I
plundered everything
but one on time somehow
oh no my 41 months
oh yes
okay
playing one of these
whatever this is
it's candid stuff
uh Castle
this looks very questionable
it looks fun though
looks very fun
where's my meat made them three those
are made in three Gambit FTW in Rose and
let's go yeah
don't on beside me
could have taken the Rook my Knight's
hanging
what is happening here
this is really messy
looks fun though
oops
there we go
oops
there we go okay
oh man
I'm determined not to lose raiding
points and you calling Roddy
play one of these
whoa King D7 unexpected bomb cloud
what to do subscribe so many things to
do
it's a pin
hi Eric pick a card any card uh King of
Spades
or Ace of Spades
I hope I picked the right card
hmm
there we go
thank you just Carol
okay 36 points
just bought a do you even real Cliff
tank top one year subscribing oh thank
you
this guy shags
oh I see the notification from earlier
yeah have fun wearing it at the gym
okay each one push
um
foreign
position
waiting a piece here
oh
yeah it's kind of falling apart for
black
there we go
Steve asking hype train
not sure if that's a question for me or
a question for chat
also thank you champ 1977.
I'll playing this opponent again
oops
it's risky
very risky stuff
in a lot of trouble here
just down the piece
appreciate the rain
from Omen OMG something
yeah if you're just joining I'm a little
bit short on time
I'm doing my best to survive
foreign
oh
okay I hung a queen there
foreign
what are you drinking is it prosperity
no
that was my first loss
ah that was my streak it was a nice
streak
and decently first place
oh what to do
yeah not the proudest opening that game
thank you Stephen Gray
hard fought
yeah
okay let's try and rebound okay
competition doesn't get easier though
play one of these
oops
foreign
foreign
move
[Music]
oh that's close
I was close had to avoid The Rook trade
oh okay
no stream in this game
um
foreign
man
[Music]
so if you're just joining I'm berserking
every game because that's what won the
poll
so a welcome toggy welcome back toggy
good to see you actually typo shout out
to Josh
um okay berserking continues
okay we're doing this again
don't mind this
now we're trading Queens maybe maybe not
[Music]
I'm cycling meeting
foreign
I'd made in one in the final position
too that's sad
oh a little bit too slow there
okay still in first
oh there's a good streak to start the
tournaments may just try and end strong
Grindelwald
oh no
I hung something
treat this as a gamut Maybe
coming back
still
ah a little bit slow there okay time for
one more game
yeah we have to finish strong not weak
Mr Kusha
are we gonna fly
we might play
a rating is taking a small hit
okay final game probably
unless I can
get this over with really quickly
I already like the opening really like
the opening
foreign
B4 would have chopped my knight for a
moment
don't hurt me
foreign
what's faster than a speeding bullet
while speeding hyper bullet
well there's not count for the
tournament
one's just stalling
a accounts for the tournament let's go
okay I finished strong
uh 47 points
yeah I had some tough games there
and some good opponents
anyway I hope people enjoy that
I mean this is all chats doing
I ran two polls at the beginning one to
determine between
rapid Blitz and bullets and then one to
determine between berserking and
nonperserking
so
this was my destiny